el país llegó hasta este punto
esencialmente porque las medidas que
habían adoptado los líderes tanto a
nivel federal como regional simplemente
no estaban dando los resultados
esperados alemania había estado en un
confinamiento parcial desde principios
de noviembre y en ese confinamiento
parcial habían permanecido abiertos los
almacenes y abiertos los colegios pero
es claro que es el confinamiento parcial
solamente pudo reducir muy poco los
números de nuevos contagiados y sobre
todo los números de personas que han
muerto por el coronavirus aquí en
alemania y de ahí que los líderes
empezando por la canciller angela merkel
pero también las diferentes regiones del
país se vieran abocados a determinar
este confinamiento total a partir del
próximo miércoles es una decisión muy
difícil para los líderes alemanes pues
obviamente habían tenido como meta
principal dejar los colegios abiertos y
los comercios abiertos algo que por
supuesto a partir del próximo miércoles
no será posible en particular durante
los días de navidad toma se habla de
cierres en plena temporada navideña una
oportunidad para recuperar las pérdidas
de los últimos meses que tan afectados
se verán los comerciantes
se verán muy afectados los comerciantes
de hecho serán los que se vean
probablemente más afectados por estas
nuevas decisiones ya los dueños de
restaurantes por ejemplo se habían
acostumbrado un poco a estar cerrados
bajo el confinamiento parcial y habían
recibido ayudas del gobierno pero ahora
por supuesto el cierre de los comercios
se añade a ese confinamiento parcial y
es claro que los comerciantes se verán
particularmente afectados en una época
en la que pretendían recuperar buena
parte de los ingresos perdidos en el
resto del año de ahí que el gobierno
alemán y en particular el ministro de
finanzas o la sol se hayan anunciado que
las ayudas económicas de parte del
gobierno se extenderán de tal manera que
los comerciantes puedan recuperar por lo
menos parte de lo que habrían podido
ganar en esta época navideña